foreign
okay everybody we're ready to ready to
start now many apologies for the for the
delay
um Alicia do you want to counter or
somebody count us down
we'll just give Keith time to take his
seat
welcome to this meeting of mid-suffolk
District Council cabinet
I'm councilor Susie Morley leader of
mid-suffolk District Council and I will
be chairing this meeting today
just remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
and finally we'll be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please members make sure you're
logged in and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will we be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'm now going to move to the agenda
item one apologies for absence
we have received no apologies Chan
thank you
item two is to receive Declarations of
pecunery other registerable or
non-registerable interest by members are
there any to declare
okay thank you item three
is MCA slash 22 20 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
of September 2022 the minutes are
attached as a supplement
does anybody have any
um questions
no
do I need a proposal
can I have a proposal please councilor
flatman and a secondary
thank you Council platman and a second
councilor headingham thank you
and we'll move to the electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that is that a nine votes for chair
that's unanimous thank you very much
item four is to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
thank you item five questions by
councilors non-received chair
item six uh matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committee
the chair of the overview and scrutiny
committee councilor wellum will provide
a short overview of the scrutiny process
which took place on Friday last Friday
the 30th of September in relation to
item 8 which is our mid-suffolk parking
strategy councilor Willem
uh thank you chair I I've also would
like to report back on the council tax
reduction scheme either now or later
in fact um we we reviewed both uh on
Friday
uh The Joint overview and scrutiny
committee welcomes the parking strategy
and has the following comments
members expressed concern over the
uncertainty in predicting parking
capacity and expressed the need to
update predictions of car use and car
park use as the project moves into the
implementation phase
there were queries over the governance
of parking strategy implementation
and a request at the business case for
the implementation plan be made
available for scrutiny at an appropriate
time
also information bulletins at Key stages
of the implementation phase
the collected data shows that some 40 to
50 percent of Journeys to a car park are
1.5 miles or less
the strategy needs to encourage
implementation of proposals to
discourage car use by providing
opportunities with Journeys to be
undertaken by other means
this will involve working with Partners
including the County Council and the
sustainable trans travel officer
members asked why there was no data
um problem areas and suggested producing
a heat map showing reported instances of
enforcement and issuing a penalty charge
notices in Hot Spot areas
the emphasis needs to be on trip
reduction not increasing the number of
car parking spaces
the strategy seems to accept that spend
in town centers increases when on-street
parking is permitted
officers should be asked to review case
studies conducted in towns where the
reverse has been shown to be the case
members expressed concern about the
lacks of lack of flexibility in the
strategy data was collected before the
sharp increase in fuel prices and cost
of living crisis
transport to school often leads to
on-street parking a strategy for
reducing the problems caused by parent
parking needs to be developed probably
with the County Council
members suggested that work is needed to
investigate the often unsatisfactory
parking of vehicles for car and Van
sharing this is particularly along the
A14 corridor
members agree that the strategy has a
limited scope as most car parking spaces
are under the control of others
especially on street parking
and members were not persuaded that the
strategy could be used to influence
planning policy
in respect to the car tax of council tax
reduction scheme
um the options before cabinet today uh
were were reviewed and
the the committee recommends option
three
the committee considered the option
three has the following advantages over
the other options
it removes uncertainty for residents it
reduces officers workload especially in
issuing revised tax bills
and with option three no resident loses
out with a change from option four which
is as is
thank you chair
thank you councilor Willem
well just remind
what we when we come on to discuss the
uh parking strategy that we are
considering the strategy and not the
implementation
so
I just need to ignore the implementation
suggestions
moving on now to item seven the
forthcoming decisions list does anybody
have any comments on the forthcoming
decisions list
thank you
okay item eight is MCA slash
22-22 this is the baby and mid-suffix
parking strategy
for the next 20 years
I'm going to invite the cabinet member
of the environment to introduce this
report thank you councilor Fleming
thank you very much councilor Morley and
I welcome this opportunity to introduce
baber and mid-suffolk's parking strategy
the strategy has been developed
response to a clear need
recognize for some time to address all
forms of public
and private parking within the districts
and the decision to go ahead and develop
the strategy was made by by cabinet Last
Summer
work underpinning the strategy has been
underway over the past year
we've engaged 2020 consultancy to lead
the data Gathering and consultation
process and develop potential proposals
to address the issues
we've also used the most up-to-date DFT
traffic forecasting Model X and project
growth based need into the future
and this of course will need to be
periodically adjusted to account for
change a matter that was raised at the
ons meeting last week
two sets of online surveys have been
conducted in in the districts the first
initially when the project started
generated over a thousand responses and
a second was conducted earlier this year
this was a more targeted survey in
response to some of the
specific recommendations and proposals
that had been developed
also a series of Road shows have been
put on in turns and parishes across the
districts
and having attended those in mid-suffolk
I can say with confidence that these
were extremely useful and we gained very
practical suggestions but public
commercial and residential parking and
in particular how to support our
struggling term centers shops pubs and
businesses which I think in is so
important at this time
this effort is an example of
consultation well done
and done effectively it is a credit to
everyone involved and I do thank our
officers and 2020 consultancy for the
hard work and dedication they've put
into this there is a wealth of
information in the work which will be
drawn upon as the plans develop as part
of implementation
some of the proposals are
straightforward and inexpensive others
are more ambitious and costly and these
will be taken forward into an
implantation plan
to assess deliverability in proposed
time frames for making desired changes
taking this forward will involve close
working with stakeholders towns and
parishes and probably most importantly
the County Council
I look forward to taking this important
work forward to the next stages and hope
you can all support it
I just note the recommendations that we
are agreeing today
that the background evidence reports
provided to support
to note the background evidence reports
provided to support the strategy to
approve the new parking strategy for
mid-suffolk and its proposed
recommendations accepting that some
recommendations may require full
business cases for approval by cabinet
later
and 3.3 to agree delegated authority for
the director of economic growth and
climate change in consultation with the
portfolio holder for environment to
deliver proposed recommendations to the
creation of a focused implementation
plan subject to business case approvals
which will be required thank you
thank you and do we have a second a
councilor gold
thank you very much chair and and thank
you councilor Fleming for
um a a very comprehensive introduction
to the report and the strategy uh and
now I'd like to join in commending uh
this piece of work and and the strategy
and particularly the uh the consultation
process that has gone alongside it which
I know certainly in in my own ward has
been enormously uh appreciated
uh I think one of the strengths of this
piece of work is the fact that it is
evidence-based
and uh this is the right way to go about
things to make your policies and your
strategies on the basis of evidence I
think too often and elsewhere uh in the
government business we see the opposite
we see
policy-based evidence making but here
this is uh sound a sound strategy based
on evidence which has been carefully
gathered uh carefully analyzed and very
clearly presented and I know just
speaking for a moment about my own patch
and I I think that I people and I have
really appreciated having their
experience of trying to park as it were
validated by the by the data uh by what
what the the evidence says makes people
think feel that they aren't been
understood and and listened to I just
like finished by reinforcing the point
that the chair councilor morning made
which I think is a very good one because
it's very easy to confuse strategy with
implementation
and we are here looking at the strategy
there is provision within the
recommendations from moving then into
the preparation of business cases and
and implementation plans and of course
this is where the real business happens
and I look forward to that that stage
but to finish as I began by really
commending this this piece of work and
and the officers work in conducting the
the consultations thank you very much
thank you councilor Gould do we have any
questions from cabinet
do we have any questions from any other
members present
okay
who wishes to start the debate
okay so the recommendations I'll just
repeat them before we go to the vote
um
to note the background evidence reports
that have been provided to support the
strategy
to approve the new parking strategy for
mid-suffolk and its proposed
recommendations accepting that some
recommendations may require four
business cases to be approved by cabinet
at a later date
and to agree delegated authority for the
director of economic growth and climate
change in consultation with the
portfolio holder for environment
to deliver proposed recommendations
through the creation of a focused
implementation plan which will be
subject to any business case approvals
required as part of the previous
recommendation
so I'm going to now ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that is uh eight votes four and that's
unanimous
sorry Chad that is nine votes for
apologize
it's still unanimous thank
you thank you very much
um moving on to item nine this is MCA
slash 22.
22.
it's a check Factory yes exemption of
the right to buy receipts
for new Council houses from pooling
if I can invite the cabinet member for
finance to introduce this report
thank you madam chairman
I'm pleased to give a brief introduction
to report MCA
22-22 on the exemption from pooling of
right to buy receipts for Newcastle
housing
cabinet members and indeed anyone else
reading this report will surely have
noticed a statement in paragraph 2.1
this rather succinctly reads there are
no other available options
and the reader May conclude this could
rather limit debate on this report and I
have to concur
whereas we previously had to pull right
to buy receipts which were then subject
to restrictions and time constraints
the regulations now permit that on the
right to buy sale of any new homes built
since July 2008.
the receipts can be retained with no
conditions or time constraints
these receipts can be spent on any
eligible HRA Capital purpose affordable
housing regeneration projects are indeed
repaying HRA debt
we can apply to the government for
exemption from pooling and the
recommendation in paragraph 3.1 ask
cabinet to prove as doing that
so without any more do I'd like to move
that recommendation and ask for a second
thank you
thank you councilor white Ted do we have
a seconder
um yes I'm more than happy to Second
this recommendation thank you councilor
headingham
do we have any questions from portfolio
holders
questions from any other members present
does anybody wish to debate this item
okay so the recommendations are that
accept application for exemption from
hauling for all right to buy receipts
from the sale of existing Council homes
built or required since July 2008
and homes built or acquired by the
council going forwards is approved if
you could start the vote thank you
thank you Chad the vote's not in
progress
thank you chair that is nine votes for
and that unanimous
thank you very much
item 10
MCA slash 22-23
council tax reduction
working age scheme for
2023-24 at consultation
so I'm going to invite the cabinet
member for finance to introduce this
report thank you
thank you madam chairman
for my second report today I'd like to
introduce the report MCA 22-23 which
relates to a consultation on the council
tax reduction brackets working age close
bracket scheme for 2023-24
report outlines proposed changes to this
scheme and seeks approval from cabinet
to enter a period of formal consultation
before seeking adoption of any revised
scheme by cabinet and full Council in
early 2023
members may recall that the first
council tax reduction scheme
applicable to those of working age came
into effect from April 2013.
it offered a maximum reduction in
council tax to eligible households of 95
percent in other words a minimum payment
of five percent of the council tax which
is a little over six pound per month on
a Band-Aid home and perhaps 950 to 10
pound per month on the band D home based
on 10 installment payments
now I must confess that in principle I
have previously supported the view that
all about the poorest pensioner should
make some albeit very modest
contribution towards our Vital local
public services and indeed I still do
however as explained in detail in
Section 5 of the report the operation of
this current council tax reduction
scheme is administratively very
burdensome
what's on Facebook may seem quite
straightforward it's actually greatly
Complicated by the need Under Universal
Credit to have monthly reviews as
individual incomes fluctuate
changing circumstances prompt a
reassessment of the council tax
reduction award which consequently
requires the prediction of a new council
tax bill and payment profile
a new installment plan defers payment
and then just before the new installment
Falls due Universal Credit May again
recalculate and the process starts again
so this causes confusion it involves
officer time in making these
recalculations it involves printing
costs and postage costs
I mentioned earlier the modest amounts
of these charges after the 95 reduction
these small balances are difficult to
collect from those unwilling or indeed
on a sorry unable or unwilling to pay
the recovery processes themselves can
lead to costs in excess of the modest
amounts out for collection
so there is therefore a compelling logic
to simplify this project process and to
eliminate these five percent charges and
to move to 100 maximum reduction
and I'll tell you the ministry of costs
outweigh the amounts we receive
ourselves as a district council from the
current scheme
but given the additional Financial
pressure everyone is experiencing during
these current hopefully temporary
inflationary period it makes this change
timely to assist our most financially
challenged residents
so as the report explains to make
changes to the council tax reduction
scheme first requires a period of
consultation
we must consult with other precepting
authorities council tax libel persons
there's a receipt of the reduction
various debt and finance advisors and
landlords and the process and timetable
explained more fully in the report
I've tried to keep this introduction as
simple as possible but there are
complications and therefore a number of
options have been considered which are
laid out in detail within a report
our section 151 officer is here and can
assist me if members have more detailed
questions
but prior to questions and debate
I'd like to move the recommendations in
section three asking for authority to
consult on option three which will
simplify the council tax reduction
scheme and move to a maximum 100
reduction thank you madam chairman
thank you councilor might do we have a
secondary councilor Richardson yes yes
thank you
do we have any questions from portfolio
holders
councilor Fleming
yes thank you um let's have a couple of
questions about this
um first is it
other changes going to be cost neutral
to the council
and the second question is
will the proposals when they are
implemented
be reviewed in the future are they
subject to review I realized that the
whole thing needs to go out to
consultation however is the plan also to
include a review of how the new scheme
is working and within a particular time
period
thank you councilor Fleming
um in terms of is it cost neutral would
it be costly is it yeah or will it be
cost neutral to the council
from what I understand looking at all
the figures that I've seen it should
actually be marginally cost beneficial
to as a district council so I say the
cost of the administrative costs
outweigh the amounts we receive
ourselves as the district council
because as you'll know I think um we
only basically retain about eight
percent of the total council tax that we
collect
I doubt it will be cost neutral to the
County Council and I don't know this is
and I guess also not cost neutral to the
police
um but this of course is why we are
Consulting with them
so that's answer to your first question
in terms of the second question and I
might need um some assistance here for
me since we'll buy one officer but my
understanding was this would be a
temporary situation for one to two years
and in which case we would later have to
revert to the five percent maximum but
perhaps you could just clarify that
um yeah absolutely spot on and the only
thing we would need to do in Council
flaming would be to go out to consult
again if we were to revert the scheme
back to the 95 so we would bring that
back as a decision here to yourselves
okay so is that is it clear that this is
um intended to be a short-term measure
to be reviewed or is it just sort of put
out there to be reviewed if and when
someone raises the question
we can certainly make that clear in the
consultation I think Ipswich did
something similar as well so we can
build that into the consultation that
it'll only be a one-year scheme and
we'll be going back out to consult the
following year so we can make that clear
thank you I think I would like to see it
made very clear in the consultation that
the proposed changes will be for a set
period of time and they will be reviewed
to see how they're performing and or
whether the way the whole thing is
calculated could be further simplified
so that it's not as as burdensome on
people's time I think I feel there's
still quite a bit of work to be done on
this topic that you know we're not
seeing today in other words
I would just remind you that this is a
consultation for one year only
does anybody else have any questions
any other members
question no
no anybody wish to debate
councilor Whitehead Passover just added
in terms of I think perhaps where
Council family is coming from
um the uh this scheme has been previous
scheme has been in fact for eight to
nine years and it's taken some while to
get people who'd never paid counts tax
before used to paying this these modest
figures and I do have some concerns that
um if we go to a zero for a short period
a bit like to me it's a bit like the
increase that was seen in the Universal
Credit where it was put up for 20 pounds
a week which was a quite a generous
extra thousand pounds but when that was
taken back politically it was it was
quite a lot of difficulty so that's
that's my only concern here but um yeah
they say that the logic is there that it
is a clumsy scheme and does need
revising
2023 3-24
and to authorize the director for
corporate resources following
consultation with the cabinet member for
finance
to initiate the formal consultation on
the proposed revision to the mid-suffolk
district council brackets working age
council tax reduction local scheme
so our governance officer to conduct the
vote thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progressed
that is nine Roots four and that's
unanimous chair
thank you very much indeed
um just before I close this meeting
I would just like to say a few words
um
Emily Ewell
this is her final cabinet
with us as mid-suffolk and baber and I
just want to say thank you so much for
all the work that you've put in you've
you've been here for as long as I've
been a counselor longer obviously since
I've been a counselor
and your your steady patient guiding
hand is is endemic throughout the
council so I would just like to say a
really huge thank you for all the work
and all the effort that you've put into
keeping all of us on the straight and
narrow and to wish you all the best in
your your new Council next week so thank
you so much Emily I really give you a
wrap
[Applause]
um so thank you uh the next meeting is
scheduled for Monday the 7th of November
at 10 30. I look forward to seeing you
all again in a month's time thank you
all very much